un policier australien est venu porter
secours à un bébé kangourou
inondations donc ça se passe dans le
nord de l'Australie dans l'État du
Queensland donc il va il va très bien la
pure partir vous le voyez
le retourne pas dans l'eau petit
kangourou Skippy reste avec nous le dos
déformé par 25 ans de tourisme une
association thaïlandaise de défense des
animaux partage la photo de cet
éléphante âgée de 71 ans dont la colonne
vertébrale a subit le poids des
touristes qu'elle devait porter jusqu'à
6 personnes en même temps son dos
devrait être arrondi comme sur cette
photo d'un autre animal diffusé par
l'ONG avec ses images l'objectif de la
sceau est clair décourager les touristes
tentés par une promenade à dos
d'éléphant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est où le bonheur il est où
il est où à l'Assemblée Olivier Veyron
s'est planté de noms à la beaucoup fait
rire ça a beaucoup moins amusé le député
qui venait de l'apostropher le ministre
de la Santé Jean Castex avait été invité
par le député Jean-René Cazeneuve le
ministre de la Santé François Brown
avait été invités
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
traduction on sait pas si simple que ça
personne dit est-ce que vous allez
désormais si vous avez dit que c'est
très simple
vous savez ce qu'on va faire on est là
et puis moi je vais faire Laurent
Geoffrin je vais faire Laurent Geoffrin
voilà moi je vais faire Pascal alors je
vais faire Laurent qui parle tout leur
voilà ta gueule
tu la fermes bordel
non mais sans déconner tu vois pas
content
j'en ai rien à [__] tu t'assois tu
n'as rien à [__] on m'entend ouais ça
va pas du tout pourquoi je te le dis la
veste non latitude
j'en ai rien à [__]
demain je te mets sur France Inter avec
Sofia
[Musique]
il faut voir comment nous bat
comme on nous parle
ça y est il va recommencer lui avec son
instrument là arrête on dirait un
moustique tu voyages non non tu la vois
la Ligue du désert à l'horizon les roses
de sable
[Musique]
si tu me frotte tu vas avoir le génie
qui va sortir
je crois qu'aujourd'hui là en plus dans
les débats de société où on parle où les
jeunes parlent beaucoup de gens et du
genre machin ben moi je j'ai beaucoup
vécu ça je l'ai pratiqué comment dirais
vraiment de façon concrète c'est-à-dire
d'être à la fois féminin masculin je
pense que que ça ne se discute pas c'est
quelque chose qui existe c'est à dire un
sexe ça se déplace pendant la vie et
donc on peut moi j'ai eu une période
homosexuelle puis maintenant je le suis
plus 69 ça aurait pu être pire mais il y
a quand même 131 points à aller chercher
c'est un signe
et croyez-moi c'est pas parce qu'il
vient de Lyon une étude effectuée sur 20
crash aérien a démontré que les
passagers assis à l'arrière à des 69% de
chance de plus de survivre 69 % les
sièges situés aux issues de secours sont
aussi intéressants en cas d'évacuation
plus vous êtes près d'une sortie de
secours plus vos chances sont élevés de
vous sentir indemne mais vous voyez
c'est mieux d'être à l'arrière de
l'avion pourquoi alors c'est pas cher
ils vont pas mettre la première derrière
[Musique]
ça y est on est arrivé qu'est-ce que je
déteste aujourd'hui
[Musique]
on fera un plan à trois
mais ça va pas et oui on attend toutes
vos questions avec vous participiez sur
la sexualité 41 555 par SMS à le
docteur.fr #5 et on est en direct
participer à la sexualité
ces dernières semaines se multiplient
les hashtags les astuces pour prendre
une douche particulièrement relaxante la
dernière en date c'est la shower orange
qui cumulent 4 millions et demi de vue
la douche orange le principe mangez une
orange sous la douche afin de
s'imprégner du parfum de l'agrume selon
et bah selon la tic-tocuse qu'a lancé la
tendance tu profites du parfum d'agrumes
qui se mêle aux vapeur d'eau chaude tu
auras une toute autre expérience de la
douche promet-elle plein de trucs sur
Tik Tok qui me cassent les couilles
[Musique]
les conseils beauté ou même les mecs qui
veulent faire c'est les qui te disent
comment draguer une femme espèce de
prolo immonde
qui te dit j'arrive avec ma Lamborghini
et tu crois que ta gonzesse va résister
je rêve de traverser des grands villes
du métier de Mandal formidable pour
rappelons que toutes ces tendances que
vous voyez sur Tik Tok ne s'appuie sur
aucune étude scientifique le fait qu'on
y voit aussi de jolis influenceuses se
doucher explique sur moi une grande
partie de succès je c'est vidéo sur les
réseaux c'est peut-être plus dû à ça
qu'en fait que elle se douche avec une
orange quoi disons que j'ai été
particulièrement attentif à ce challenge
en fait
cinq habitantes du quartier egg battants
atterhéran pour la journée du droit des
femmes le 8 mars dernier elles ont dansé
en bas de chez elle sur la chanson calme
down de Rima elle ne porte ni voile
nijab non elles ont les cheveux lâchés
et sont toutes habillées d'un crop top
des manifestations encore en Iran la
mobilisation qui se poursuit en
particulier pour dénoncer
l'empoisonnement des jeunes filles à
l'école mais des garçons viennent en
soutien des étudiants qui disent leur
soutien aux jeunes filles regardées en
s'imposant à eux-mêmes le port du voile
en cours ce qui donne ce genre de
clichés sur les réseaux sociaux et par
ailleurs une autre image du genre